y los primeros 100 días de un gobierno
son considerados como una primera
evaluación de gestión que se puede decir
del gobierno de castro hasta el día de
hoy
así es pero yo que los primeros 100 días
aunque no se puede hacer una evaluación
profunda de lo que está haciendo un
gobierno pero si dan luces de cuál es el
camino que está tomando y en ese sentido
creo yo que hay cosas que realmente dan
un mensaje positivo a la ciudadanía y
también a la comunidad internacional y
luego hay otras cosas que generan un
poco de preocupación dentro de las cosas
positivas creo yo que además de toda
esta ley integral para la protección de
las mujeres en un país caracterizado por
una alta tasa de femicidios y una alta
tasa de impunidad más del 90 por ciento
por femicidios realmente es una noticia
positiva lo mismo también la derogación
de tres leyes que han sido fundamentales
para el sostenimiento de la dictadura de
juan orlando hernández la primera de
ellas la ley de secretos oficiales que
establecía un manto de oscuridad y de
impunidad en todo lo relacionado con el
actos de corrupción en el país por otro
lado la eliminación también de la ley
sede
implica una recupera de la soberanía
territorial del país y también la
eliminación de la ley de empleo temporal
que reducía drásticamente los derechos
laborales de la mayoría de la sociedad
hondureña en ese sentido estos son
ejemplos de cosas positivas y uno que es
muy importante es la solicitud a
naciones unidas- de la instalación de
una comisión internacional desde lucha
contra la corrupción y la impunidad que
en este mes de mayo va a hacer una
visita exploratoria naciones unidas para
ver las condiciones en ese sentido y
también se ha hecho una propuesta de ley
para
que la elección de las altas
magistraturas del estado se haga en base
a meritocracia y no en base a
compadrazgos político de eso en términos
generales es algo muy positivo que sin
embargo hay cosas también que generan
preocupación y yo me centraría
particularmente en dos
una que tiene que ver con digamos ahora
el presupuesto nacional ha colocado en
primer lugar al tema de desarrollo
social lo cual es positivo sin embargo
en segundo y tercer lugar esta defensa y
seguridad y el problema es que el
ejército y la policía están vinculados
con el narcotráfico y es una pena que se
les esté dando recursos sin que existe
un verdadero proceso de reforma
estructural y depuración y por otro lado
también es preocupante y con esto
finalizó el alto perfil y el
protagonismo que está teniendo el
presidente manuel zelaya esposo de la
presidenta xiomara castró y esto está
generando muchísimas dudas de quién
realmente está gobernando